num num num num num num sanam comes thum
thum thum thum
hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome to tasty planet back for seconds
now this game is actually the first
phone game that I've recorded on this
channel I played iPad games but I guess
they're technically the same thing but
this one is really really cool because
it's well a lot of people would probably
relate it to the idea of agario but in
all honesty it's less to do with that
and more to do with Katamari Damacy dama
C I don't even know how to say it
properly and what's even weirder is the
setup that I have to record this because
I got it I got my iPhone mirrored to my
giant uh computer monitor and then I'm
just dancing around with my finger
touching the phone which is even more
bizarre but I'm just trying to get by so
everyone bear with me so these two
scientists made what is called grey goo
and if you don't know about grey goo
it's a theoretical idea where scientists
made a nanomachine that was capable of
rebuilding itself and actually
duplicating itself using things that are
in the environment and this is bad
because once these things are autonomous
enough they would eventually consume
everything on the planet while also
rebuilding themselves to the point where
they get so big that they actually start
consuming people than buildings then
whole continents and eventually the
entire planet would be reconstituted
into even more grey goo and that my
friends is a very bad all sorry red I
like it how it change colors into the
thing that I last absorbed into my body
come back here ah
you escaped this time but don't feel so
lucky next time
i-it's actually awkward because the
controls are me sliding my finger
crossed this thing whereas also I could
tilt my finger around there but I'm not
gonna do that to myself because I'm not
a masochist this white would all the
evidence on the internet points - I
don't like to punish myself all that
much no they poor this is a squeak and
it's gone and that's what could happen
to you if you let the grey you become a
reality
you but hopefully that doesn't happen
hopefully a lot of the doomsday
scenarios don't happen because they are
very sad and very scary can I be done
yet rat done little more how about this
there we go attaboy okay so eventually
throughout this game it also kind of
relates to a game that I played a long
time ago called like a little fishy or
something like that oh by the way those
are the scientists that were too stupid
to actually make this thing be careful
around larger entities some of them will
hurt you if they touch you now this is
more in relation to where it comes to
little fishy because little fishy
actually was a game where you are a tiny
itty-bitty fish in the ocean of a bunch
of bigger fish but those little bastards
didn't know oh it's gone for them
because you actually ended up growing
much more intensely than they planned
okay so I'm assuming he doesn't kill me
right off the bat he prolly just drops
my size down a little bit good candy
good kitty I don't know why these cats
aren't going for all the different rats
that are out here hey I can absorb that
I can absorb that I can absorb the rat I
can absorb that not that yet but you're
next
see I'm steadily steadily steadily
making more and more progress and then
the cats that ported me will now be my
ah not yet wow man what kind of
lab is this where this just rats
escaping all over the place anyway son
seem like very sanitary conditions I
mean all things considered especially
the scientists that accidentally fed me
oh it's your time I'm sorry that execute
feels bad but oh well survival of the
fittest baby I gotta get you down into
my gullet no matter what because I must
survive I guess I could play it up here
yeah sorry kitty oh god that's so sad oh
my god fifty rats three cats Oh God just
wait till it gets even worse and works
cuz it's gonna get bad it's gonna get a
whole lot worse before it gets better
and it's never gonna get better that
Time Machine sure looks tasty if you get
big enough maybe you'll be able to eat
it oh that's good wait why am i small
again what the hell happened I thought I
was gonna be bigger well this is a bunch
of where did this go wrong huh
it may have been spurned by the success
of agario and now slippery Oh which I am
gonna play more of I will play more slow
Larry oh I have not forgotten that since
I'm actually good at that and it doesn't
relate to the douchiness of others
around you whoa hello okey-dokey then
hey scientists what are you gonna try to
stop me I'm your uncontrollable creation
you can't do anything to stop me
I am fully autonomous and with plenty of
bloodlust in my soul you guys are gonna
die dead oh this is so cool though but
you can see what I mean when I say
there's related to Katamari Damacy the
mossy cat Katamari whatever you know
it's called don't judge me I don't know
what to call things I don't know how to
word right god I wish my finger wasn't
so sticky I'd be able to slide it around
a little better don't take that out of
context whoa I'm escaped you better run
yeah now we're getting into the thick of
it now things are going wrong and it was
their fault for leaving so many pieces
of lab equipment strewn about on the
floor like this it's just irresponsible
Yami um thank you sorry kitty
you gotta go all these guys poor pets
they're just walking around they're so
helpless they don't even know yes more
and eventually I'll get that time
machine right there oh but this so cool
I always loved if you guys ever saw like
the scale of our universe it's like this
little program online or through little
website that lets you see like zooming
in all the way to the smallest known
particle and the smallest theorized
particle all the way down and down and
down and down - or up and up and up and
up - the largest object in the universe
or the entirety of the universe I forget
what it actually is but you can see
through stars and planets and cells and
like individual strands of DNA all the
way down to subatomic particles and
fundamental particles fundament
fundamental particle yes I got a time
machine oh good a my time machine poof
pretty go
the Chroniton particles in my time
machine must have caused a local
temporal distortion the goo travel back
in time
him oh why am i small again is
oh well
but I guess I must carry on oh oh I'm
gonna go through time again and then
come back to the future and then destroy
everything even though if I was
absorbing everything throughout all of
the entirety of time pause the game by
okay good to know but I didn't need to
know that because I'm too good for this
Wow rocks
I guess my diet sure has changed from
cats and rats to rocks but in the past
what are you gonna do what else can you
do
mmm indeed I'm gonna get you spiders in
just a little bit just bear with me I've
got a lot of growing to do emotionally
and physically
oh hello jeez doofy look at amber oh
those not spiders I thought they were
spiders obviously ants what am i stupid
probably bury all the big ants now in my
gullet I'm gonna continue on my rampage
whether you like it or not goodbye
goodbye also if you hear any grouse
crunching sound that's because cheek is
in the room and she's currently chewing
on a bone so ignore that and it
definitely focus on the gross crunching
that's happening as I'm eating all these
ants and an eco-terrorist disaster
that's gonna cause a rip in the fabric
of time and that's a snail god damn so
yeah
it's basically just gross all-around
just everything eating everything else
which is kind of like wow okay larvae
YUM but a bear grylls this up rocks more
rocks love rocks so happy it's just so
interesting because I always love seeing
things from different perspectives like
that's what made spore like potentially
interesting back when you know it was
first before I was actually released and
everyone knew what was actually coming
out of the game and it just became a
dick monster Simula hello buddy how you
doing I'm gonna get you eventually but
before I became a simulator of making
the most horrifying dick monster that
you possibly could
it actually was interesting because it
seemed like it was going to actually
open up a ton of avenues to exploring
like the possibility of how these
creatures survived and like more
intricate ways that they go about life
and stuff like that and more more like
a grander understanding of things on
that scale from the very smallest cell
to a large and complex organism and it
fell short admittedly it did fall short
of a lot of its goals but you know that
idea was still there and hopefully it
could have retained but this in reality
to everything else is just mindless
eating and I'm totally on board with
that because it's super fun oh the grub
oh man I can't get that image out of my
head when Bear Grylls like ADA ate a
huge larva and it just kind of kind of
exploded it was really disgusting but it
kind of just exploded everywhere also by
the way I'm not good at this
ah true it's an old shrew you know the
music is oddly cheerful for me being
such a horrible thing that's eventually
gonna destroy all civilization and
everything that could ever hope to be
hello turtle I like you but everything
that could hope to be in the future
because this is obviously if the
butterfly effect is real then this is
having the worst effect because I'm
about to eat me up some butterflies and
it's not gonna be good for the world but
oh well at least coming close anyway
oh come on how much more do I need come
on give to me there we go yep butterfly
effect confirmed and everything is gonna
be horrible yay destruction oh sorry oh
so sad they just want to live and I come
by they didn't even think that anything
was gonna happen oh that's true oh god
stop me before I kill again I take a lot
of time on this because I'm not exactly
good but I'm also trying to talk at the
same time and I can't see cuz my big fat
finger is sliding all around the screen
it caused me to block up everything but
that is whatever the hell this was
called they totally forgot what was it
called what's called tasty plan that's
what it was called
so that is tasty planet thank you
everybody so much for watching this game
is really fun the only unfortunate thing
is that it does cost money but I think
there's actually an ad-supported version
on the store as well so you can play for
yourself obviously I can't provide a
link but thank you everybody so much for
watching
you want to see this game again let me
know in the comments below thanks again
and as always I will see you in the next
video hey how you doing today I only
have 10 seconds to beat him as what